hey there and welcome in part two of the
rain series we're diving into footprint
chart strategies there's a lot of
information and real examples ahead so
make sure to watch Until the End we'll
also be sharing some tips to make your
trading strategy even more effective
first what does rain stand for it's our
unique acronym that includes reversal
absorptions imbalances and non belief
we'll go through the setups in this
exact order one quick note if you're not
familiar with the terminology or how to
set up a footprint chart check out part
one of this series and if you're unsure
how to identify support and resistance
levels don't worry we'll cover that in
the next video subscribe so you don't
miss
out all right let's get started we've
prepared two charts the left one shows
the strategy during a downtrend reversal
meaning a reaction to resistance while
the right one demonstrates a reaction to
support meaning an uptrend reversal in
each explanation the left chart will
serve as an ideal textbook example
whereas the right chart will have less
ideal conditions in both cases the
strategy remains valid the first
strategy based on a reversal is the most
common its key condition is that the
price returns to the point of control po
of the signal candle the price moves up
to a certain level this could be a price
Action level like a weekly High monthly
open order block a volume profile level
a pending limit order in the smart doom
and so on depending on your trading
style what's crucial is that the signal
candle closes in the direction of the
trade we're about to open in this case
it should be red have a negative Delta
and close below its P level we assume
this level will act as resistance so we
prepare to enter a short position this
footprint closed red below its Po and
with a negative Delta all the conditions
are met if any of these conditions are
missing the strategy is invalid and we
stay out of the trade Don't Force trades
stick to the setup for example if the
candle closes with a zero Delta or right
at its POC the signal is not valid for
rain setups an additional bonus is the
presence of a finished auction near our
resistance or support level 0 X7 in this
case this isn't a mandatory condition
but it increases the probability of a
successful trade so all four conditions
are met after the previous upward move
the price reaches a resistance level the
candle forms in the expected downtrend
Direction closes below its Po and has a
negative Delta we're now preparing to
enter with a limit order placed one tick
below the PO the one tick below rule is
important because the price doesn't
always return to the PO of the signal
candle or there may be too many orders
at that level preventing the execution
of our
order since the PO acts as the Market's
first barrier a retest followed by a
continuation in the expected Direction
makes for a stronger trade setup the
left side of the screenshot shows a
textbook example the next candle opened
here moved up slightly the wick tapped
the level one tick below the POC of the
signal candle we entered with a limit
order and the downtrend began in an
uptrend things are a bit trickier let's
say we have some support meaning the
price is approaching a level from above
and we're getting ready to open a long
position the conditions are met we have
a green candle that closes above its p
and has a positive Delta the previous
candle might also have a positive Delta
but that's not critical what matters is
that the green signal candle which
aligns with the expected Direction has a
positive Delta in this example the
signal candle has an unfinished auction
at the bottom however this doesn't
matter because a finished auction
appeared in the previous candle with 1
x0 at the low while this isn't a
mandatory entry condition it does
slightly increase the probability of a
successful trade so all entry condition
are met we have a green candle
confirming the expected move an uptrend
in reaction to support it closes above
its Po and it has a positive
Delta we're ready to enter the trade
with a limit order one tick above the
POC of the signal candle notice that the
next candle moved up drifting away from
the entry level and our limit order
wasn't filled we don't adjust or move
our entry level we just wait as you can
see it could be the next candle or even
the second third or 10th eventually the
wick of another candle dipped below the
level where we had our limit order
that's when our order was filled the
trade was opened and the market moved
up sometimes you'll see a double POC
like here this gives us extra
confirmation that the market sees this
level our pattern works because the
candle in the expected Direction met all
three
conditions important note each of our
four setups loses its validity if any
candle breaks the high of the signal
candle in a downtrend or the low of the
signal candle in an uptrend at that
point the pattern isn't valid anymore
let's move on to live charts there will
always be a blue line on the charts
representing a support or resistance
level for our setups any of the rain
patterns must appear at a specific level
not just in an empty space for example
in this candle series there were several
conditions that looked good but there
was no reaction at the resistance level
we need to be patient and wait until the
price reaches our
level pay attention to the volume values
shown in Blue on the candle statistic
indicator and the Delta which appears as
a green or red
number the price just broke through the
resistance level we've been watching if
you look closely at the top of the
footprint you'll see finished auctions
and an
imbalance this doesn't mean everyone
suddenly started buying but it does
suggest that there was no more interest
in trading on the left side of the
footprint as we we talked about in the
first part of our rain series the right
side of the ask on the footprint shows
either Market bu orders or limit sell
orders this means some people were still
selling above the resistance level with
limit orders or Traders started buying
at the market price expecting that the
resistance was broken and the price
would keep
Rising it's important to pay attention
to the volume of individual
Footprints you might notice that 1,84
contracts on one 5-minute footprint are
a significantly higher amount compared
to the others this means that most
contracts were traded on this candle as
you can see the candle closed below its
P plus it's red and has a negative
Delta even though it's a very low number
minus two it meets the condition now we
have all four conditions for entering
the red candle that closed below its po
the negative Delta and all of this
happened at the resistance level as a
bonus we also have a finished auction of
0x14 at the top let's place a short
order here and calculate the risk to
reward
ratio we'll enter one tick below the POC
as usual and aim for a risk to reward
ratio of two this means we'll set a stop
loss 15 ticks away and a Target 30 ticks
away now we just wait for the price to
reach our sell order we'll place the
stoploss one tick above the high of the
signal candle just a reminder if the
price breaks a new too high the setup
won't be valid
anymore and here the price has hit our
Target this was a good example of
trading the r setup
correctly the second setup is based on
absorption so it's labeled with the
letter A on the left we see another
example of an uptrend which we expect to
reverse into a downtrend at the
resistance level in addition we notice
aggression from one side in unusually
high volum volume on one of the candles
this spike in volume is often paired
with a high Delta for example the volume
starts at
7114 then jumps to
367 the Delta suddenly goes from 3479 to
135 these are significantly higher
numbers compared to the previous
ones pay attention to the values that
appear at the top of the signal candle
in this footprint normal values are 4X 8
3x7 and 5x5 but as we approach the PO we
start seeing double digigit numbers on
the ask side 19 27 and even 38 these are
unusually high at first glance however
this doesn't necessarily mean more
participants have entered the trade
we're still below the resistance level
large players may have already opened
long positions but they won't appear on
the right side of the footprint due to
their High volatility Market orders they
had a significant number of pending cell
limit orders in this area on the right
side of the the smart Doom these orders
gradually absorbed the market orders
from retail Traders the market had
started moving aggressively even before
that and Retail Traders might have
assumed that after breaking through the
level the price would keep
Rising this is a classic example of an
absorption
setup the price started to approach the
resistance level below which the large
players had set their pending sell limit
orders unusually high values began to
form at the top of the candle the POC
was near the top and the candle closed
below its po this is exactly what we
need significant volume at the top of
the footprint marking the volume of the
day for that specific candle we then
enter with a cell limit one tick below
the PC and wait for the order to be
filled the next candle broke through the
level we entered and from there we're in
a short position the example on the
right shows an entry based on a setup
responding to support in other words a
reversal from a downtrend to an uptrend
looking at individual candles we can see
the typical values are single digits but
then suddenly we start seeing double
digigit values at the bottom of the
candle again there's no reason to
attribute these volumes to large players
selling in the case of trading at a
support level these are pending orders
either limit by orders which we see in
the do or hidden Iceberg orders it's
possible that this represents large
players closing their short positions
they likely had limit by ORD set to
close their short positions which is
reflected on the left side of the the
footprint under bids the clue lies in
the very long candle up to the level
which in this case should close above
the POC we can see that the second
candle didn't test our level one tick
above the PC and neither did the third
one until the fourth candle broke
through by one tick with its tail that's
when we entered the long position to
summarize this setup is defined by a
signal candle with unusually high volume
and often an abnormally High Delta but
the key factor is the volume it should
really stand out like 18 5180 and then
suddenly
394 this is a highly aggressive setup
and naturally it comes with higher risk
you can use it to its fullest like in
the setup on the left or to its minimum
like on the right either way the risk to
reward ratio is extremely favorable it's
definitely a setup worth adding to your
toolkit because of its potential
profitability let's move on to some
Market examples this is a NASDAQ chart
with a 5-minute time frame for this
aggressive setup the key factor is
having a candle with the volume of the
day on the chart without a doubt we
should be able to say this candle has
unusually high volume and it's also
close to our support level notice that
the average volume is around 300 to 400
contracts in this case the volume is 700
and 800 but we're already seeing a
candle with over 3,000 contracts the
Delta is also very high making it tough
to find a higher number it's also worth
mentioning that the the p on the
footprint nearly matches the support
level we're watching The key thing here
is that an aggressive entry based on the
absorption pattern should happen on the
candle with the highest volume which
closes above its POC when expecting a
long this is a basic condition in this
case we have over 3,500 contracts along
with a high Delta over 550 which is four
to five times more than the previous
candles this is our signal candle for
the entry and notice this candle also
shows a large amount of
imbalance here we even have entries with
zero on the right side of the asks the
market has sped up very aggressively
towards support which likely gave retail
Traders the impression that a downtrend
was starting but for us the key point is
the very high values we see on the left
side of the footprint the highest number
on the ask side is 129 indicating that
there were limit by orders placed just
above support aggressively absorbing
retail Traders sell orders that's why we
see the highest values on the left side
of the footprint the large players
weren't selling here but were either
closing their short positions or buying
with limit orders the candle closed
above its po one of the conditions and
as a bonus we have a 1x0 below this
isn't just a finished auction it's
what's called a silly seller because
there's only one participant left
selling at this
level so the conditions are met we have
a red candle with massive volume in
Delta and it closed above its POC I'm
focusing on two levels the point where
the fair value Gap ends and the level of
broken Support also known as the
flip we can confidently set these two
levels as our targets so I'm planning to
enter with two contracts with the entry
one tick above the P of the signal
candle we'll place the stop loss one
tick below the low again with a risk to
reward ratio of two the stop loss is set
at 10 ticks so our first Target will be
20 ticks away we'll take profits on the
first part here and the second part will
be held in until the fair value Gap is
closed this gives us an amazing risk to
reward ratio of
7.6 so we open two positions and wait
for the price to return to this
level here's something interesting the
POC of the signal candle lines up
exactly with the POC of the current
green candle
the price hits our second Target and we
successfully closed the second part of
our
position the third setup of rain
imbalances focuses on entering trades
during imbalances unlike the previous
setups where we used pending limit
orders this time we use a market order
meaning we enter the trade immediately
at the market price without waiting for
a return to the POC we'll start by going
over the details of this setup and then
we'll show another entry option that
could also be helpful this setup is is
similar to the first one but the key
difference lies in the emphasis on
imbalances that show up on the signal
Candle on the left side of the chart we
again see an uptrend that we expect to
hit resistance reverse and move down
this candle meets all the criteria for
an entry based on the reversal setup it
has high volume a change in Delta and
closes below its POC which would allow
us to place a pending limit order one
tick below the POC additionally we can
notice incomplete auctions which can
significantly increase the probab ility
of a successful
trade in setup I we focus on imbalances
that appear on the relevant side of the
footprint for a downtrend we look for
imbalances on the left side which
corresponds to the bids these imbalances
signal acceleration and strong Market
interest in the move whether it's large
players or retail Traders there's a
reason they're jumping into the trade so
aggressively the candle can quickly move
far from its POC and can be quite long
it's the imbalances that tell us it's
not the time to hesitate or second guess
so we enter immediately after the candle
closes at market price you can also
consider splitting the position into two
parts entering the main position right
after the signal candle closes and
adding the rest if the price returns to
the PO alternatively you could open the
next position one tick below the PO if
the price does come back however if the
imbalanced setup works as expected the
price usually doesn't return to that
level and quickly hits the target the
condition conditions for entering this
setup are as follows the candle closes
in the expected Direction red for a
reversal into a downtrend closes below
its Po and shows a significant number of
imbalances additional confirming signals
may include High trading volume and a
noticeable Delta change on the right
side of the chart the situation is
similar but a bit more complicated the
red candle doesn't have finished
auctions and shows lower volume than the
previous candle however the signal
candle closes above its po which is what
we expect in an uptrend and we see a
large number of imbalances on the right
side this suggests strong interest in
continuing the new trend as I mentioned
earlier this candle eventually reached
the PO of the signal candle and there
was an opportunity to add another
position however this isn't a rule and
shouldn't be relied upon too much treat
it more like an exceptional entry
opportunity when you see a candle with
imbalances don't hesitate or wait for
the price to return to the POC you
should make the decision to enter
immediately after the signal candle with
imbalances closes otherwise the price
might move away from
you this setup depends on the specific
imbalance ratio setting I have mine set
to 200% which means if one side has a
value of 15 the other side must have at
least 30 to qualify as an imbalance
increasing this parameter will reduce
the number of imbalances on the chart
it's important to test what value works
best for your instrument in time frame
we recommend starting with a 200%
setting for back testing let's take a
look at some real charts to practice the
ey
setup here we're seeing a strong and
aggressive Trend develop we have a
support level marked by the blue line
which will trade if one of the four rain
patterns shows up I can't stress this
enough don't look for rain patterns
without considering support and
resistance levels I know I've said it
before but if you skip this step your
success rate will drop
significantly this candle has already
tested the support you might think this
would be a good time for an aggressive
entry using the absorption pattern but
none of the entry conditions are met
there are no finished auctions at the
bottom of the candle it doesn't have
high volume and there's no significant
Delta most importantly it closed below
its POC whereas we're expecting a
reversal into an uptrend meaning the
candle should have closed above its POC
we also don't see any strong values on
the bid side so there's no absorption
happening it's not the right moment to
enter let's wait for a better setup on
the forming candle we can spot a
finished 3x0 auction with just three
sellers which indicates weak interest in
further trading but more importantly
there are a lot of imbalances on this
candle so as soon as it closes we're
ready to enter the market what matters
now is that the candle closes green with
a positive
Delta at the moment we still have a
negative Delta so we're waiting
we're starting to see a positive Delta
and there are even more imbalances on
the ask
side now that the candle has closed we
quickly enter a long position we place
the stop loss just below the candle's
low and as usual we set the target based
on a 2:1 risk to reward
ratio it doesn't matter that we entered
three ticks lower than the close we stay
consistent so we treat the close as our
entry level and we calculate the target
accordingly you could say this entry
resembles a reversal setup that's true
but the difference is that we have a
positive Delta decent volume and the
candle closed above its PC Plus on the
right side of the footprint we see many
imbalances which are large pending
orders and as a bonus we also see
finished auctions at the bottom as
mentioned earlier we can place a pending
order one tick above the candle's PC
just in case the price comes back to
this Zone if the price drops below the
low of the signal candle and hits the
stop loss the entire setup will be
invalid and we won't look for a
re-entry now notice that even this green
candle is showing a lot of green
imbalances we're still leaving the limit
order in place in case the price comes
back to this level even just with a wick
to double our position it could happen
quickly so it would be a shame to miss
the
opportunity but it's clear that it won't
happen now as the price is approaching
the target
level the setup worked out successfully
the last setup represented by the letter
N in the rain name is called non-belief
because it's based on uncertainty in
this scenario the price reaches
resistance and forms a candle in the
expected Direction meaning a red one
however the key condition for the r
setup isn't met the candle should close
below its POC you'll notice that this
candle has the highest volume and there
is a shift in Delta from green to Red
all of these are important signs there's
also a completed auction at the top but
there's no chance to wait for a pullback
to the PO as we're already above that
level the candle closed above the P it
doesn't matter if there are imbalances
in the candle or how large the volume is
even if it's several times greater than
the previous candle's volume in this
case the PO acts as a barrier the price
simply hit resistance and formed a POC
but couldn't break through that first
barrier its own POC this creates
uncertainty and doubt it might signal
rotation which is often followed by a
longer move in the expected
Direction the potential for a reversal
is there but we need to wait and see if
the PC level will be broken this is the
point where we can enter the
position we would place a cell limit
stop one tick below the p a sell limit
stop means it's a pending order with the
condition that the price must at least
Reach This level which is one tick below
the PC we don't wait for the next candle
to close completely below the POC we
enter as soon as the PC level is broken
at the first return in most cases if the
price doesn't hit resistance and is
ready to keep moving up the POC break
won't happen at most it will be tested
once so we place a stop limit sell order
one tick below that level betting on the
break in the second case things get a
bit trickier as often happens the signal
candle is green moving in the right
direction and has the correct positive
Delta for an uptrend but the volume
isn't bigger than the previous candles
and the Delta is smaller with unfinished
auctions at the bottom but the most
important thing is that it closes
exactly at its po which goes against the
our patterns rules so in this case the
reversal pattern is invalid the candle
should have closed at least one tick
above its po not right at it but that
didn't
happen we place a stop limit by one tick
above the P of the signal green candle
as you can see the next candle doesn't
break this level it reverses and starts
moving down the following candle
continues moving downward which might
suggest the downtrend will keep going
however the third candle breaks the
level we're watching and this is where
we would enter the
position as mentioned earlier we could
be seeing a rotation phase here this is
typical of the fourth setup where
there's no immediate reversal or
reaction and the chart shows a range
with the price staying there for some
time we're waiting for the price to
break out of that range so we can enter
the trade without delay this condition
is confirmed when the the point of
control of the signal candle is broken
to sum up the conditions for the fourth
setup are as follows the color of the
signal candle should align with the
expected trade Direction the Delta
should be in the same direction negative
red Delta for shorts positive Green
Delta for Longs and the close should
either on the left be above the PC or on
the right below it or as in this case
the close happens exactly at the PO we
wait for the breakout in place a limit
order one tick low or above the PO
depending on the direction of the trade
we're going to
enter let's move to real charts and
practice the fourth setup n which
represents uncertainty here you can see
that a range is starting to form notice
that these candles have relatively large
volume if we look back we can see that
the price was in an uptrend
interestingly a similar pattern appeared
here where the candle had decent volume
closed green and there was an unfinished
auction at the bottom there were even
imbalances
however the key condition wasn't met we
didn't identify a support level and
didn't base our trade on The Logical
level there was a red candle here that
closed below its po so it might have
seemed like a short entry this green
candle has an unfinished auction at the
top en closed below its POC but it has a
negative Delta so it doesn't qualify as
our signal candle for the rain and
pattern this candle also has a negative
Delta but the next candle has a positive
Delta it's green and there's a finished
1x0 auction at the bottom since the
condition for closing above the poc in
the reversal pattern wasn't met this is
a case of uncertainty so while we can't
enter with the reversal pattern we can
enter using the N pattern we'll place a
pending stop limit by order one tick
above the P of the signal candle if the
price breaks this level we'll go long we
set the stop loss one tick below the low
of the candle and our Target is set with
a 1 to2 risk to reward ratio
the stop loss is 39 ticks so the target
will be 78 ticks this candle is the
first in the range that meets all the
entry conditions for the Rainin pattern
it's green has a positive Delta and
closes below its POC we're waiting for
the price to break the level one tick
above the PO of the signal candle
the price has now reached its Target
let's review the situation there was a
range that could have been traded using
a breakout strategy after the uptrend
but we entered on the breakout of the
signal candles po do you realize the
risk a Trader would have faced trading
the breakout and how much better was our
entry you might have noticed that there
were no support or resistance levels on
the chart this time but in reality the
price was moving around the previous
swing high that was our level we were
expecting the breakout of that high in
the continuation of the
trend so these are the four rain setups
based on proper footprint reading
besides an idiom no rain no flowers
comes to my mind we'll adapt it to no
rain no trades if none of the setups
appear or if any of the core conditions
isn't met then don't enter the position
we always have to keep waiting for rain
and patience is one of the most
important qualities in trading you have
to be able to wait three important
recommendations the four patterns can
serve as both entry signals and triggers
for other trading strategies the rain
patterns help identify critical Market
reactions to support and resistance
levels they will guide you in deciding
whether or not to enter a
trade each pattern becomes invalid as
soon as a candle breaks the high or low
of the signal candle when that happens
the pattern no longer applies most
importantly avoid chasing trades wait
for the right pattern instead thanks for
your attention let's take our trading to
the next level with these patterns